all right uh this is session number
take a deep breath um
i'm just thinking or this morning after
a
discussion someone said why don't why do
you call the er file what uh wouldn't
log be a much better name and uh
absolutely it's much better so
uh it's sold and and uh our
log files are gonna be called log
instead of air from now on
um there'll probably be other things
that people are watching this on
videotape uh
some months from from the from today um
they'll probably be
having a listing of tech 82 or the
module numbers are a little different
and it'll say
and there's it will say log all already
and they won't understand what's going
on i imagine they'll be able to sort
this out uh
make some sense out of a few of the
remarks we make anyway even though
tech is still is still
absorbing these these new ideas
someday it'll be too late to absorb any
new ideas so we've got to have all our
good ideas very soon yeah
dan
you've got an objection to log
log does conflict with the top 20
system convention which is that they're
the output of batch files
do you care
oh i see you mean if you if you gave a
batch processing thing it would give you
a log file for that too
yeah i see so these three letter
names have been how about ln for natural
log
okay well we'll we'll play around with
this again again in discussion okay
um
the topic of the hour is
dvi files and uh
um
actually i'll spend a little bit of time
talking about what tech does as far as
generating the dvi files are concerned
but i i think i'll spend more of the
time just explaining uh exactly what the
meaning of dvi files is the reason is i
i
most of your work is not is going to be
doing something with dvi files uh
and that's outside the scope of tech
tech considers its job is done when it's
written a dvi file but that's when the
hard work starts you have to
you have to get it uh you know uh to
make a really good system you should be
able to handle many people wanting to
print their dvi files in a big hurry and
you you might want to queue them up
somehow
send them to a printer you have to in
order to print them you have to figure
out how to how to
convert the dvi files to whatever the
printer wants to see
and
combine it with pixel files or something
for fonts and so on that's where the
work is and so you're gonna have
that's the unless you can find some
system that already uh
does this for you they exist for things
like the versatech and the and the canon
and uh
um
and uh you know the work doesn't have to
be done over and over for every device
by every person but otherwise that's
that's going to be a major part of your
work is uh
is something that isn't really part of
tech 82 at all it's something that goes
on after so you can be sitting there and
have tech 82 and it'll do all these
great uh operations and give you a dvi
file and there you'll be sitting with a
dvi file
you probably want to know at least what
that dvi file contains and that's what
i'm going to talk about this hour
and we also have dvi type so you can you
can list the dvi phone it would tell you
what the page would look like if you if
you had a printer to to see it on
that's about the best we can do with the
software that we're giving you on our
tape
okay dvi file stands for device
independent and this is our goal is to
as that tech should be able to produce
output that's that can be used on many
different devices and the
drivers have in fact been written for
lots of devices and
we believe that any reasonable device
can be driven by a dvi
reading program
um
that section um
let's see device independent file format
is part 40 of the
write up and it starts now at module 498
which with the description of the of the
of the
dvi
this has gone through three generations
the version zero
uh was the first uh
was the first proposal for for dvi then
based on the experience again with that
uh we came out with version one one of
the big differences was the way it the
bytes were packed in words
because most people needed them
for example on a 36-bit machine they
needed the
leading bits to be
uh i mean the trailing bits to be zero
instead of the leading bits to be zero
when they tried file transfer protocols
on these things and uh
that was one of the major changes
between version zero and version one but
um
now
the presents uh conventions here are
version two
which are
similar to those in version one except
that all that uh we've added more op
codes and uh renumbered all the op codes
so you so you can't uh
um
print with you you have to change your
dvi software slightly
it has the same structure but different
numbers uh to the um
to the codes and and uh
and essentially the the revisions that
were done at this stage were
uh to clean things up
fill gaps in the in the previous thing
and make it sort of uh uh
complete and more symmetrical and
in an order that looked a little more
reasonable
now
i guess i should
go first into the discussion of what the
dvi file looks like similar to what we
said with the tfm file dvi file is is a
again a packed file of 8 bits so it's a
sequence of codes 0 to 255
and whatever order you want to put those
on on your file doesn't matter as long
uh because we just put them we just put
it out as a sequence of uh
of 8 bits
and
i guess i could also present one on the
screen like we did for the other case so
you can see what they look like on on
this machine so let's see i probably
have it
i probably have a dvi file in my
directory now
nope
okay
let me see
um
excuse me
well i i think what i'll do is this i um
i'll use that as the last viewer but i'm
going to try to run tech and make it
make a dvi
now
so let's see
i'll run any tech
which is the
thing that has nothing at all
pre-loaded
what's going on i'm swapped out this
never happens at sale
we've got four four thousand
we got four million words of memory
requested by all the users at this point
okay well i got in anyway um
okay now
that's the debugger that's that's
talking to that i'm talking to
and um
i better make this a pretty short test
program
oh tech pool doesn't match tangle me
again so this failed to sum check what's
going on here
okay i'll run the pre-loaded version
instead of any tech
sorry about this i have to uh
um anyway we might as well make up a dvi
file
um
and uh
at this point i have to
kill us some of the things that are
pre-loaded because this is trip this is
trip that's pre-loaded and i really
don't want that so
i've got to kill every par which is set
to some ridiculous value
that would happen in every paragraph now
i'll define a new font let's say font
one equals cmr10
and then i'll
i think
just say hello and get out
so um
oh i gotta select font one too
it's the current font
and then i say hello and get out
uh so let's try end
okay in overfull box
um
that's okay excuse me
uh it's it you see that where it says
hello there has a vertical rule after it
that's because it had an overflow box i
made my h size zero so no wonder it's
over full box okay
i didn't set a size to anything okay
um
now uh
well i could print it too we can go over
and see if it says hello on there
but now anyway we have a dvi file and
it's called techput.dvi
that's what happens if you don't give a
name if you uh we said last time um
you know if you say input to paper then
your names are paper but if you but here
i didn't give any name
and so
um
see i got some mail here too
okay so anyway uh
the uh name the default name if no no no
that was specified by the first thing
you did is t-e-x-p-u-t
okay now over in jack saw we could read
this message that says hello uh maybe we
can see it later on this afternoon
but the dvi file itself is in there so
we could we can first print it in
octal format and then we can print it in
more symbolic form
uh textput.dvi
a bunch of zeros there at the beginning
it's not too long okay that that's the
file
and uh
um now let's
let's explain so anyway it looks like
that we'll come back and and uh be able
to understand what all those sevens are
and stuff in a few minutes
okay so that's that's a dvi file is
supposed to be short uh it's supposed to
be reasonably compact way to describe
uh
printing and it's also supposed to be
easy
for a machine to read efficiently
these were designed by david fuchs and
uh
i think those two goals are fairly well
achieved
of course my uh
this isn't all saying hello this is
mostly
overhead that's involved with uh with
all dvi files uh uh saying what version
number they are and things like that
okay
the um
uh the instructor the the dvi file
is best thought of i think as an
interpretive routine
uh we could have the lights on now
and because i'll be obviously going out
it's best thought of as an interpretive
routine uh
like uh or at least from the old days we
call them interpretive routines these
were
programs that go through and and uh
consider that they are
uh defining another
another computer
and we are we um the interpretive
routine are the central processing unit
of this new computer and we and the
interpretive routine is really
a set of op codes and offerings and so
on something like uh machines actually
executing their hardware but we're doing
it in software
and this the op code that
comes along is the first thing so so the
uh
beginning of it each byte and the dvi
file starts out as an op code and then
depending on the op code it has certain
operands that that that it expects to
follow
the up codes start on
module 500 page 174 of our listings
and
the first op code is a very simple one
set character 0
and
it's just a 0. so if our dvi file has a
byte of 0 this is going to mean typeset
character 0 from the current font
we wouldn't give that first we'd better
set up a current font because the
current font is undefined when we start
the machine that we're simulating here
or defining in this dvi machine
is
has a few registers one of them is the
font register f it's an integer font
numbers can be anything any 32-bit
numbers so
this will handle
quite a few fonts and uh in case you uh
now tech will never generate however for
a font
for a font number larger than the number
of distinct fonts it handles which is
something some quarter word so typically
we would never get a very large font
number ourself but
um
dvi is defined to allow large font
numbers because tech isn't the only
system producing dvi files
then we also have a current position on
the page and that's h and v horizontal
and vertical coordinates on the page
it's just like cartesian coordinates
except upside down that that is if v
gets bigger we move down instead of up
but h gets bigger we move to the right
so h and v are these things and the and
zero position is the upper left corner
of the page
uh we start on every page at zero and
with font the current font undefined
the uh
then we have four other registers called
wxy and z and these are used to keep
track of spaces that we're going to be
using over again
um when we when we skip around in um
typically the amount of space that you
move
is is repeated and so we can save space
in the dvi file by not repeating the
information over and over again w and x
are two registers for horizontal units
of spacing y and z are two registers for
vertical units of spacing
then we also have a stack
built in our
hypothetical machine and the stack
contains values
h
v w x y and z all these other registers
get pushed on and popped up
at various times so that
we can
uh
in one bite we can say push and one bite
say pop and uh and thereby change a lot
of these values go back to a previous
state
uh the current fund is not pushed and
popped
and uh
and this is really the uh because uh uh
it saves it it seems to be better not to
um
now all of these things are 32 bit
numbers including a sign so we go minus
2 to the 31 up to
plus 2 to the 31 minus 1.
this is a two's complement type of a
thing and and there's a they're given as
uh
when we say um spacing um
h and v
we
we mean in terms of something
um
some unit of measure of course
now the unit of measure
in version 1 dvi files was called the
rsu
for ridiculously small unit it's
intended to be such a small unit of
measure that rounding errors don't
matter if you accumulate a thousand of
rounding errors uh and you're off by a
thousand rsu's the i still won't see it
or maybe a hundred anyway the
impossible to notice
um well
the uh
uh
the around the uh
actual unit of measurement though is not
defined particularly uh
we don't call them rsus anymore in this
new report
but there's a
there's a conversion factor at the end
of the dvi file two numbers the
numerator and denominator
that uh we that that says if you
multiply by the numerator and divide by
the denominator then you get
units of i think it's ten to the minus
seventh meters or ten to minus eight
meters something like that so it's so
basically we do have a metric system um
involved here tech always sets those
numbers to to the right to the right
value so that that the units that tech
outputs is scale points uh same as tech
uses everywhere else in its internal
convert which is pretty ridiculously
small unit so scaled points is now two
to the sixteenth of a make one printer's
point um is rationally converted by a
certain fraction into these into the
metric system in case uh
it's for for other other programs
writing dvi files
would find other units
to be appropriate
okay now the dvi type program shows in
great detail that's one of these things
in the techwear book uh shows in great
detail how we recommend rounding
positions
in the dvi file to lower raster devices
i probably should meant to talk about
that a little bit later um but there's
but you see you we have two kinds of
units we have these ridiculously small
units which we're going to be giving our
our measurements in in the dvi file and
then you have pixels
of something on on your actual device
and you have to convert between the one
and the other the proper way to do it is
to keep most of your arithmetic in the
in the
dvi units and do rounding two pixels at
key times like at the beginning of a
word something like that
okay now
if you want to set types that character
number zero from font from the current
font f you just give byte 0 and what
could be more compact than that i mean
okay similarly one
up to 127
will will typeset characters 1 to 127
respectively now we couldn't do this for
all 256 characters in the font because
we only have 256 op codes and so if you
have to set um a character number 128
you do it in 2 bytes and there's a
instruction set one
this one's called set one
which is followed by the character that
you're supposed to set
and so in the notation in the book it
says c bracket one
in the brackets is the number of bytes
that we assume the operand is
129 is set to
which is c2
and 130 these are not generated by
tech82
this would be to set
um
three byte and four byte characters
there's even a set four
so all of these
um
possibilities
set four would say that that uh
so if i gave 131 then it would say read
in the next four bytes
and then whatever those four bytes are
that's the number of the character that
you're supposed to set next in the
current font
so we can handle
fonts with two to the 32 different
characters in them uh the dvi format has
not
tried to be restricted it's supposed to
be useful for uh
even cons even
things now uh
also people might use this somehow
they might have some convention for
these bits like this reflects the color
or the or something like that
who knows but uh
uh right tech will only output c1 for
the characters 128 through 255.
okay
now
this is typical of the commands in dvi
that there will be
versions one two three and four
depending on how many bytes you need for
the operand
so that the command will tell you uh so
if you if you uh are only
uh if you only need a two a two byte
number then you use the op code that
says that says so
that only two bytes are are needed
afterwards so this is a three this is a
two byte total command one for the op
code and one for the character this
would be a five byte total command
question
no dave what
um
now all of these characters not only all
these set instructions not only uh types
at the character but they also move h
to the right by the width of the
character
so
this is this this is set
character 0
and h is set to h plus the width
of that character
so the dvi reading programs have to have
access to the to the width information
for each character just as the just as
tech does
and
so dvi reading programs will use the
same some check that tech had
in order to make sure that it had the
same that it makes the same assumption
because tech isn't going to tell the dvi
file how wide that character is dvi
reader
is supposed to get that out of some
other thing now we put this information
also in the pixel file so that the pvi
reading program doesn't have to read
both tfm file and pixel file and so meta
font will put this information out twice
with with the same sum check so that you
can make sure that your your information
is consistent but this is important for
packing the
packing the total length of keeping the
total length of dvi file down
okay
now
there's also a set rule character which
is 132
and this one is followed by two operands
a and b each four bytes long all four
byte long parameters are signed um
that means that uh if you have a four by
long parameter the first uh it could be
between minus two to the 31 and so on
looking at the first bit of the sign
however in these in these uh
one and two and three byte characters uh
it's always plus
so the charac so the the uh
the range here is uh for example in c in
set two is zero to sixty five five
thirty five
um
not you don't have a negative character
number f for these but a four byte
number is always considered to be signed
so that we uh don't overflow uh the
constraints of a 32-bit computer
uh we're supposed to be able to read
this on any 32-bit computer which would
want a four
four byte number to be considered a
signed assigned integer i guess
um and uh the set rule instruction
is like setcare that it also will will
advance h after the rule's done now the
root now a is the height
and b is the width of this rule and if
if the
height is zero or the width is zero
then we don't do anything
um
except move by b if similarly if any of
these are negative so b is minus five
for example
we wouldn't put any rule there because
what's a rule that's uh minus five
things wide it's uh it's uh
kind of invisible
or you could imagine tearing a hole in
the paper or something i don't know but
um all it but it will move h and h will
will decrease by five in that in that
case
now
um there are rules specified in the tech
82 manual so that you should so that uh
the rule rules
there are things in the in this manual
that say how we could get consistency
between tech and metaphone so that if
somebody
designs a character using metaphone and
has a certain conventions about
how that he's drawing a straight line in
his character and then we have a dvi
command that says sets a rule
that we can guarantee that we're going
to line up the pixels perfectly so that
the rule have the same number of pixels
high as the other and those are spelled
out in the in the book
precisely
so it should be possible to
to uh have consistency across across
these things uh without uh no matter
what the rounding conventions are so
we've designed a thing with with that
uppermost in our mind that we should be
able to to ensure perfect alignment this
is important for example uh embarrassing
cases if you have a
our large radical sign now actually has
a little bit of a a
of a top to it um
because otherwise the on such a large
case it would look bad if you if your
variable was too close to it so we give
this extra space in
in the radical sign itself well then
tech is going to put a rule next to that
and uh the the uh
positioning is based that the
the
uh the the rule the the baseline of the
square root sign
is exactly the same as the baseline of
the rule this means tech computes the
same number for both of these and uh and
they're given in precisely the same dvi
coordinates in terms of v here
so they'll be exactly the same height v
above the line this rule will will be
set by us by exactly the height of this
character and uh therefore we should get
exactly the same output if if the dvi
servers are implemented properly this
should be exactly as thick in terms of
number of pixels
even if we move this up on the page one
third of a pixel the rounding should
have been exactly the same for both
calculations for this one and this one
wasn't true in the present version of
tech and
um
but we get positive
alignment in the other the other version
this by the way big square root would be
an extensible character
but the top part has this
has this feature
um
set rule i i might mention goes up above
the that that uh the rule starts at the
lower left corner the current position
hb is the lower left corner of the
of the rule and then
so this is your reference point and then
you move h to the width of the rule
afterwards
now corresponding to these
set commands we also have put commands
um
like um
133 i believe is put one i won't write
them all out
partly i don't have
have room for it put one followed by a
one character code and the put commands
are just like the set commands like this
would uh uh put one last like set one
you give a character code that you're
supposed to type set the only difference
is that h doesn't change
this is when you're setting characters
above each other for example you would
do you you might like to do that
if you're doing an extensible character
like this and just put out
the
pieces the the rep the replicating
pieces
um however i don't think tech
82 actually generates that command
because we're not we don't have
character nodes in vertical mode
um so there's put commands and put rule
and so on
all right the
operation 138 is a no op
it does nothing
and it just
in case you have you for some reason you
want to fill space
or blank something out
it's something that tech doesn't
generate
but you can have these uh between dvi
commands if you want them for some some
reason or other convenient to your
software
um you can't put a no up
in in the middle of a program it has to
be between between commands you couldn't
put a no up between the set one and its
operand how is how would you know that
that was
you know that it wasn't supposed to be
character number 138 that you were doing
there but you could what you can put it
between commands all right
okay well anyway there's i don't have to
give these numbers anymore let me just
give the mnemonics so
noah and then there's not bop
and um
e up
and pop
um well push comes before pop but
there's a lot of these
that seem to rhyme
they the the
bop is beginning of a page
and
this is the long one
it's followed by
by
11 parameters each four bytes long we
don't expect this happens very often
typically
but it's followed by c0
4 bytes up to c9 four bytes and then by
another four byte parameter of p
which is a okay now um
p is a pointer to the previous bop in
the file
and if it's the very first pop in the
file
p is minus one
so this allows you to go backwards
through the file skipping back uh pages
from the end of the file back to the
front and we use this on some machines i
think on the canon they use it for
example because the
the paper comes out and you would like
it to be stained and stacked uh
so that it's better to print the last
page first otherwise after you get your
output you have to you have to go like
this to get them right
so
so they read the file backwards
and uh isn't that right john
yes
it takes so long to pick up the
microphone
man a few words okay we've got so so uh
um
this allows you to go back through the
file from to p p to the previous pop
okay
um beginning beginning of page the the
c0 to c9 are the values of tech
are cross-reference values that a person
can use in order to identify a page
location and tech puts out the values of
the first 10 counters
it's count 0 to count 9
for this purpose so you can identify a
page by
uh
by uh it's kind of know what what you
usually get on your screen is just the
value of count zero
um but if you but sometimes people like
to you know have
have more substructure to this and so
david wanted to be generous so he put
all he put ten of them out uh i don't
know if anybody's ever used more than
three but our convention that we've been
using with some success has been to
print them out uh with dots uh for
example
1.2.1 would be a page where count zero
is one and count one is two and count
three is one and then when we give the
starting page command on um uh so say
we'd like to start at a certain page if
we said one
dot star dot two this would mean find
the first page that has the form count
one is one count the count zero is one
count two is
two and count one we don't we don't look
at
then it would print out um
it also depending on how many dots we
got it would print out
that uh as it's as it's printing on on
the
on the console of the printer it would
say i'm printing page
uh something and it gives the it would
give the first three counts if i
specified that if i specified in my
starting
if i said my starting page number was
one star two star
then it would give me four counts uh to
to show what page it's at
um
this convention seems to work out
reasonably well for displaying page
numbers as you're doing if you have a
question
one bob for every ship out exactly
ship out uh
uh it puts out a bop
and an
e op which is end of page right
so
now when you give a bop it starts out
initializes all its registers to zero
and uh the current font is undefined and
the stack is empty
you're supposed to push and pops are
supposed to to be uh all contained
before you get to the e up through the
stack should be empty when you get to
the end of page but the end of pages is
uh is a time when
um you you print everything now
um when you in most cases when you're
when you're implementing this
you'll be doing eop
you'll be doing a lot of computation at
the time of eop that's not reflected in
my dvi type program
because for most devices you have to
sort the information into order by some
coordinate or other either horizontal or
vertical or something now the
things that you get out of tech are not
guaranteed to be in any particular order
um
they tend to be in in order but not
always because subscription superscripts
for example or people uh doing for funny
things with negative glue could
certainly uh
review the order that comes out in is
somehow
what we would call pre-order in computer
science as far as the list structure is
concerned we just unwind the list
recursively and take things as they as
they come to us uh that tends to be in
order and that tends to help sorting
routines but tech doesn't do the sorting
itself that's the responsibility of your
dvi reading program if you if you need
to sort some devices don't need it some
some devices do but what you typically
do is you get to a bop and then you
start
you start
looking at the rest of the bytes and
start and this this gives you
coordinate positions and characters
and you start building a table and then
when you get to the eop i'll put that
table
we also build in
protection against overflowing the table
so if the table gets too full then we
sort it and i'll put that
that part of it right there and then
continue on um with the next partial
part of the page too and sort sort each
part we will break up this
information if we have to on our alpha
type
serving
things this turned out we didn't need it
until people started using our
our programs for vlsi layout and so
right now uh
for example when you get a sun
workstation it was printed uh because of
dvi files and tech and uh our our uh
software for driving the typesetter
because we
we the the masks that were made for for
uh some of the boards we'll print we're
done with software that had a huge
number of commands between bob and yup
okay
um
oh now push
says take your stack and
your hb
wxyz registers go on to the stack and uh
and on top of whatever was there before
you don't change any of their values
and pop takes those takes the values
from the stack and puts them into those
registers forgetting what the other
registers were
and uh
um typically
why why would you do that well it's
something it goes something like this
but most pages we might say consist of
lines
and so um so the page is a vertical list
and then when then it comes to this
point and it gets to the baseline here
and then it says
push
and now it goes into a horizontal list
and starts moving across this way well
when it says pop later on we're right
back here
then we can do a mo a vertical motion
gets us to here we push again and do
this kind of computation at the end this
vertical motion will be the same as that
one so we've recaptured the same the uh
the
previous value we don't have to phys we
don't have to push is a
pop is a fast way to back up to where
you were before you see
helps a lot with leaders and other
things too that would tend to fill up
these dvi files
okay now the other the other commands
are just for
for uh
motion primarily and they there's so
many of them
they fit into a simple pattern
and this is uh right one right two right
three right four i'll just say right one
as a representative of this class and
it's followed by an
amount of uh vertical of horizontal
motion b
now in this case b is assigned quantity
so this is between a minus 128
and um
and less than a plus 128
is um uh in in these in these commands
where we're talking about motion we use
so uh we use a sign number so right
might actually send you to the left
um
uh and the same with right two right
three right four depending on how many
uh right one is actually rather uncommon
because these uh dvi units are so small
that that we would have to move at least
uh at least 200 or something in order to
see it
but it could happen um
they but usually right too is is in the
is in the ballpark of the kind of
motions that we'll actually be making
and since we since the set character
commands already do the rightward motion
uh most of the time this will be moving
from word to word or just doing a little
kerning between between letters of the
word
then there's w0 or
w1 to w4
and
interestingly this this the definition
of the write command
it does two things it says h
to h plus b
and it also sets w
to b
so the amount that you move by is saved
in this register double oh wait a minute
no no that's not right
no i'm sorry it doesn't do anything
sorry w1
w1 is a command that says h to h plus b
there's a b b 1 associated with this guy
h to h plus b
and w to b
and similarly w 4 is a followed by a 4
byte parameter and does the same thing
now
w0
just sets h to h plus w
so that whenever we we
have the right
amount of motion already in register w
then we get by with a one byte command
and uh
tech has a neat way of uh that seems
amazingly effective on producing one
byte commands on on the
examples i tried uh it it learns the
kind of spaces that you're making um
and the type and uh it uh you know in
normal text uh each line typically has
one or two spaces that are there uh one
for kerns and one for uh between letters
between words
math formulas have another kind of
spacing that goes around the
operators and things like that but this
seems to learn them very quickly so that
we get by with one byte commands quite
often
uh there's x0 through x for same deal
but using x instead of w we have these
two registers each one can be used
there's no uh
the present version of tech uses w only
for uh space between words and x only
for kerns but uh tech 82 um has an
algorithm that tries to be too tries to
be clever
uh in assigning these and so you can't
assume that it just because it's an x
that it's either a current or something
else that generated it
um now now similarly to the right and w
and x we have down
y and z exactly the same except you
replace horizontal by vertical motion in
all the commands
so that takes us up to operator z4 which
is 107
170.
we still got up to two to go up 255
possible opcodes well the next 64 of
them
um are all just to change current font
so 171 is set font zero
and um or font num zero excuse me
is the official name fntnum
and uh up to um
whatever
which is
63. this command sets f to 0 and f 63
that's all it does but uh
you know we got uh set the current font
number and then we have font one
two three and four two for uh for
font numbers of one byte two bytes three
bytes uh four bytes so if we um now
check assigns its fonts internal codes
uh and the first font that you name
i will get number zero or actually in
internally it'll get number font base
plus one but this will convert to zero
in the dvi file and so only if you've
given more than 64 distinct fonts in
your job will you ever need of this
command 235 which is the fnt1
instruction which is followed by
a one byte
font specification
and you could have
any anything up to four bytes uh one
proviso is that that you're not allowed
to declare font number minus one font
number minus one is is the only one
you're not allowed to have
well there's two more op codes and then
this then it's done
um
front uh
4 is 238 so 239 is xxx
this is for this is what comes out of
the xsend instruction and so you people
will be interested in this for
extensions to tech when somebody says x
send in tech
um
x send and then you um
uh give you give something here
this is expanded as if it was in a
the um
any macros are expanded in this text and
the resulting characters are placed
after an xx x command in the dvi file
associated with the current h and v
where you are where this x end
appeared in the paragraph
and um
uh it's followed by one byte
um that tells how many bytes are
following and then by the text in text
in in text internal uh ascii code that's
m bytes long
now uh here if people feel strongly
well okay somebody suggested the other
day that he doesn't want to restrict
this m to 255
that he would like to be able to have x
send
a huge long piece of text coming out
here
right now we're restricting it to 255
maximum
uh through xn my my uh
inclination right now is that if you
want to send
a large amount of information your best
but better is putting it in a file and
naming that file here
but
if there's a strong call that we need
really an xx2 instruction that will take
a two byte m
and then we could go up to 65
k bytes i wouldn't imagine
or wanting to put stick more than that
into the middle of a dvi file for sure
uh then um what we would have to do is
uh change the
few programs that we already have
reading this kind this version of dvi
this if that change is ever to be made
it should be made now because uh
it could it could be done uh by a few
people in a few minutes
before this gets frozen but
but next year be very difficult we have
to say that's dvi version three
and uh so we still have a time to make
such a change the only idea i've ever
heard of that might
might be useful for uh
putting into present dvi files so you
might think about that and give me some
comments on it after
yeah right now we just have xxx limited
to a maximum of 256 bytes in this in
this xn
uh the last op code is
uh which is the post amble and that's so
that's the strange part of dvi files
which i'll be talking about soon
um
op quotes 241 to 255 aren't defined and
uh they're they're uh uh
so it so it wouldn't be that hard to
switch in xxx1 and xx2 there we still
have a few left for
for future use
and no no really great ideas as to what
to do with them roger
uh yeah on the current dvi you have a
trailer bite of some sort that comes
after the post gamble and i don't see
that in this list
yeah i'll talk about that that doesn't
it it it only it only has meaning at the
end of the post amble so it's uh
so that's
okay
now um
uh the post amble
is is uh so if we're reading from the
front of the from the front of the file
we get to uh we get to 240 this should
occur only right after an eop after end
of page we should never run into a bear
post amble
um
however tech would tech generated one
the other day and i found out why
uh i think it was in the middle of a
this can't happen error
um so it didn't get to the end of a the
this can't happen error occurred in the
middle of the dvi in middle of a ship
out so
you know it terminated right away but
but in order to close out the dvi file
it wrote a post gamble
so um
so it is possible you know to protect to
generate this and the dvi
reader would reject the the file then
when it got there and and and saw a post
demo right in the middle of a page
now
the post gamble is uh nay is is one of
the words that uh we had to make sure
that we could hyphenate because it
doesn't appear in the english language
dictionaries uh and in fact uh the
present tech hyphenation admin calls it
a post campbell um so we we had to put
it in that list of words that you looked
at that was there yesterday to to get it
hyphenated properly
um it was it's a kind word but it means
that we're giving information that comes
after instead of before
but we really read it first um
we need the information first but tech
doesn't know it until the end so
um now
it's uh
it would it
the alternative of saving enough room at
the beginning of a file for it was uh
was was the uh worse than what happened
so david had this neat idea and it seems
to be working fine to put the
information at the end of the file
um
and so at the very end of the file comes
this uh this post amble which is a huge
long list of information it's in
module 503 of your book uh tells you
what it is uh i'll just read it to you
first the first thing after the pst
is
a four bytes that's the pointer to the
final blp in the file so this is the
if there weren't any blps at all you get
minus one there but this is the this is
where you can start going backwards
through the file
uh then comes the numerator and
denominator that i told you about
telling you what your dvi units are
defining those
and
then comes what is it m which is the
magnification parameter so person in
tech said magnify 2000 there you're
going to get the number 2000 here this
is something that
is supposed to be applied globally
throughout the entire file
after everything else has been done said
and done also magnified by this amount
so it effectively it just uh if it just
uh goes in with the numerator and uh and
denominator and uh and the true
calculation to convert uh dvi units to
uh
um uh to um uh these ten to the seventh
minus seventh meters
um
is um
uh m times n divided by a thousand d
that's the that's the factor that's used
we generally compute that in floating
point arithmetic
now
um magnification passes through only in
that way in tech unless you say ask for
true dimensions you can you can ask for
true inches true points or something in
in a dimension in tech
and and if you ask for
say two true inches and your
magnification was 2000 then tech would
convert that to dimension to one inch
so that later on when you magnify it
you get two inches
but if you haven't said true anywhere in
your text file then the only effect of
the magnification parameter is to change
this
thing in the post angle that comes out
here
when you write dvi software it's also a
good idea
to provide the user with uh um i mean in
many cases it's a good idea to provide
the user with a chance to override the
magnification option at printing time
and say uh just don't take you know just
uh
uh pretend that uh the the tech job uh
said to magnify a little bit more so so
that uh you don't have to rerun the tech
job just can say okay spool is at uh 50
larger
if you have the fonts at that size you
can do it
some people asked about about storing
fonts at different magnifications we
we
since we can say cmr10 at 15 points in
cmr10 at 20 points that means that we
should have it in our
in our font library uh
these uh these options perhaps
and
how to name them well
uh depends on your on the system you're
using the uh the dover software requires
a certain naming convention that has
quite a lot of structure but on other
systems like when we use the canon we uh
uh uh
we work with with just the ordinary file
system in our computer and uh a file
that's been
that's been um magnified uh
to uh 44 000 for example
gets a gets a suffix uh um it'd be
called cmr10.r40
and and at ten point it would be called
dot r10
and so the server just looks for a font
file or pixel file with us the suffix
that matches the amount of magnification
on our alpha type we use more digits
than that but it's something like that
we we say
it's an ant file for the alpha type and
we call it uh the suffix suns it would
be something like 1000 ant for a for for
a uh normal font and uh 12 1200 and for
font that's been magnified 1200
something like that is the so we just
put in the extension of the file name uh
the indication as to if these pixels
were generated at a different at a
different size from the from the other
one
um what we do then in our software is we
find the the
smallest size greater than or equal to
the one that we're supposed to print at
and then we try to shrink it down if we
can with with the printing hardware
if we can't do that then we complain and
say well we had to substitute a font uh
we try to substitute the closest we can
that's the kind of issue
anyway magnification is this next thing
in the post amble then there's l and u
ellen you are um
the
the uh
measurements of the tallest page the
height plus depth the tallest page and
the width of the widest page
so when we start type setting a page we
start at the upper left hand corner l
would represent the maximum height and
depth of that page w uh u is the
i couldn't call it w because w is one of
the registers of the dvi machine so l is
is the maximum of all these numbers u is
the maximum of all these sizes however
this does not
this does not tell you where the
characters really are i mean somebody
might have
had an over full box that sticks out
here or done backspacing or something on
the margins um and there might be
characters outside these things this is
just the box this the size of the box
like it was a v box was a certain height
and depth the the maximum size of boxes
that were shipped out but it's not
actually computed by the position of
of things in the box
um and uh these numbers the purpose of
these numbers is so that you might want
to put in your spooling software
something that tries to lay things out
on a piece of film
and we we wanted these uh uh things to
to um like if you you know if you can
fit four on
four
um of these pages on one uh on one piece
of your medium that you're printing on
then you could uh you could save uh
save the uh those are tend to be
expensive on some prototypes that is so
you could pack the thing yourself
but we never really have implemented
that yet we just put lnu in for that
purpose
uh we've got other ways of specifying
you know the user gives us a option file
that tells where to put
where to put the pages for for a
particular job each job has its own
option file in that way
now let's see i covered l and u then
comes t
s and t s is the
i think the greatest yeah the maximum
stack depth if you it tells how big a
stack you have to have in order to to
handle this this dvi file and t is
the total number of pages in the file
just in case you wondered
to a number of bob commands
after that is the all-important font
definitions
and uh it and tech tech will only put
out the font definitions that are
actually used
um
the
if you if you've declared fonts but
never
set any characters from the fonts it
doesn't come in the file
and uh
the font definition consists of
uh the internal font number so that you
can match it uh it's like font number
zero through 63 typically
then you've got a
check sum for the font so that you can
so that you can do checking make sure
that this that you've used the same
information that uh that tech did when
it generated this file
you got an extra scale factor for the
font this substitutes for the for the
design size of the font
and then you've got the uh
the area the font area and the font name
that are just passed to you
and uh as a as an ascii string
we do this for each font and then we
have a minus one
uh four bytes representing minus one to
tell you that you're at the end of the
fonts and that's why
font code minus one was not allowed
because as soon as you get to a minus
one
then then sn now after that that font
number minus one we're reading on in
module 504
then we've got a pointer to the post
amble command
so let's see if i can make a little
picture of that
my dvi file is going along and i've got
a -1 sitting there
and then i've got um a pointer to the
postamble command four bytes that give
the address of the post animal command
where it appeared
where it appeared here
after that
comes the identification byte which is
two
so this is version two dvi file
and then we've got out any num greater
than or equal four bytes
that are all equal to
i can let you in on a secret 223 if you
put it in hex
is df
and david fuchs is the one who designed
dvi files i believe it's a little much
too much of a coincidence so we call
this the signature bytes of the dvi file
and uh
and we and he put at least four of those
in there
and this is this is to make it possible
for
uh
if things are packed four bytes to a
word um uh to find the end of the file
by means of
routines that exist on most systems now
standard pascal doesn't allow you to
start reading a file at the end and do
random positioning going back through
the file but most systems do allow you
to do this and if you if you don't have
such a system then you start at the
beginning and zip up to the post gamble
and then start at the beginning again
and start your type setting but most
systems you can get it from the back so
you come back
to the end of the file read back over
the 223s check that you got version two
then this tells you where the post amble
is the post sample tells you where the
previous bop is if you want to go
backwards or you can go back but anyway
you can read all the fonts here and do
the do the checking the dvi
the dvi type program that we've
distributed here includes both options
and you can
and you can see the code that would read
the file in both directions
um
yeah
time is getting short but i would like
to run dvi type on this file
so you can see what it looks like on a
reasonable file
so let's go back to the computer
and see and uh i'm this was called
textbook.dvi
and i'll output to checkpoint.type
let's say
okay now it's going to ask me for um
it's going to ask me for several levels
for several things and uh it also says i
can type question mark for help
2 for a complete listing 0 for errors
only one for something in between i'm
going to get
2 for a complete listing the starting p
page
i can i can use the default uh if i said
star dot star however i'll show you that
just will print out uh
both count numbers count zero and count
one both of which happen to be zero i
guess maximum number of pages
uh is uh you know i'll just type i'll
just allow it to do a million pages if
there are that many
then it will convert things to pixels
per inch and if i wanna if i want points
instead of um
if i want points there's 727
points in 100 inches so i'll type 7227
divided by 100.
the magnification um i can
i can just say return to keep the old
magnification
on any of those i could have typed help
and i would now it's done it so i can
look at the file
text put dot
type
and this should be the dvi file that we
created
got to move it over to the right again
okay so it told me the options that i
selected
and the post symbol starts at byte
number 68 the bytes are numbered
starting at zero
gives me the numerator denominator
magnification was set at 2000 because of
the
the trip file actually set magnification
2000 so things are getting magnified
twice
and
we loaded font 3
cmr 10 at size
10 dvi units but that actually will be
magnified okay now the um
because the dvi units are are magnified
okay so beginning so byte number zero
was the beginning of of page zero point
zero
and it and if i had said star dot star
dot star dot star then i would have seen
all the counters of that page then it
says down three
four five five one one one so
so the vertical uh the register v is
moving down the page by 455 000 dvi
units
has a warning here
says the absolute value of v is greater
than zero
what
i don't understand that at all i have to
think about that
what's so bad about that
what
um
no
huh do you think so
um
that's uh now that that line is is
complete okay well that doesn't seem um
oh oh i see yeah yeah if you look up
here it says max v equals zero
uh you see uh that was the um
uh the max v is the uh largest uh
supposedly
uh largest uh v that's that you've got
and this is warning me that i've
exceeded that uh with some characters
outside of there okay
oh thank you
so then i push
um and and get my first box and i'm and
this comment here that i'm at level zero
of the stack has the following values of
h
v w x y and z the eight double h and
double v are the are rounded to pixels
which in this case is rounded to points
so i'm 14 points below the upper corner
of this thing because of probably the
baseline skip which i'm not sure what it
was
must have been seven points or something
like that for the top baseline
uh now then at byte50 of the dvi file i
selected
uh
instruction font num3
so the so i picked up font number three
font number zero one and two were
pre-loaded to be those trip fonts that i
didn't actually use uh so the current
font now is cmr10 in in byte 51 of the
dvi file i'm setting character 72 which
is abc which should be a capital h for
hello and you see down there in brackets
there's a comment
if i hadn't asked for for
level 2 which gives me everything i
would have just seen hello i would have
gotten a much more terse description
from dvi type
i've asked for everything when i said
output level is 2 here so that
transcribes all of these characters into
hello and then it set a rule this was a
rule put out for an over full box
because uh um
one thing that i had set in that uh you
know pre-loaded option was that
that every over full box you get a rule
that's five five
points wide now look at this rule it's
14 by by 10 wide
that's because it's been magnified twice
so i'm actually getting one 10 point a
rule at 10 points wide so if we went
over and looked at the hard copy that
came off the dover
we would have seen a
a rule
at the end of the word hello that was 14
points
high and
10 wide
and the hello would have been set at 20
points instead of at 10 points then it
pops and uh
we go back to the previous level of the
stack and the page and that was it so
that's the that's the idea of the dvi
file for a short program
time is is running out now
so we'll have to break and meet again
at 3 30
for our final session
the trees
you